There's a new bar
in Washington D.C.
themed after a very special
old friend.
(with accent):
It's-a me, Mario,
and I'm a alcoholic-a.
ALL:
Hi, Mario.
-Oh, uh, thank you.
Uh, thank you. -(laughter)
Uh, Mockingbird Hill is
celebrating cherry blossom
season in the most logical way
possible--
by turning itself
into a pop-up bar
about a pixelated
Italian plumber.
(upbeat tune plays
with video game sounds)
(music playing with video game
sounds, lively chatter)
(laughter, applause)
That bartender's like,
"I finally have a reason
"for this dumb hipster mustache.
-Finally!"
-(laughter)
"And I'm glad I bought
all those Shake Weights."
-(laughter)
-Yeah. Yeah.
The bar is open until April 15,
and you can get all sorts
of Mario-themed stuff in there,
like a drink called
"What Doesn't Kill You
Makes You Smaller."
And you can usually
buy some mushrooms
-from a guy in the bathroom.
-(laughter)
There is even seating reserved
for King Koopa,
but Steve Bannon likes
to sit there
'cause it's close
to the women's bathroom.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Comedians, I want you
to tell the bartender
your problems at the Mario bar.
-Dan.
-(bleep) this.
I'm gonna go to the PAC-MAN bar
and drink
until my ghosts catch up to me.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK: Yes.
Points. Very good.
-(applause and cheering)
-Very good on that one. Jenna.
This must be a Mario bar
because I'm getting
super smashed, brother.
HARDWICK: Yeah, points.
Really good.
(applause and cheering)
Very... very impressive. Steve.
(imitating Mario): You would-a
drink like this, too,
if your evil cousin Wario
was a-(bleep) your wife.
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
-(laughter)
-(bleep). -Points.
-(applause)
Principessa.
What-a Luigi?
He tape-a the whole thing.
He got a good eye-a
-for the camera. -HARDWICK:
The whole thing, while a gorilla
jerk off on a ladder.
Why he-a do this to me, eh?
-(applause)
-Why you do this to me?
It's less creepy if it's in
an offensive Italian voice.
-HARDWICK: It's way less creepy.
-It's like...
(like Mario): "Oh, I want-a
hear you breathe." You know?
HARDWICK (like Mario):
I want to hear you breathe. Eh.
(laughter)
Somebody flip-a that turtle
on its-a feet.
I can see right up into the...
All right.
ST. GERMAIN:
You...
You pick-a the wrong rest stop
to go into.
You don't see your friends
and family forever now.
I thought this-a glory hole
was a world warp.
I didn't-a know.
I thought it was taking me to...
How would I know?